[Musique]
c'est enchanteuse cette fois-ci que
Judith Chemla se réinvente révélé au
cinéma en 2012 pour son second rôle dans
Camille redouble la comédienne revient
en 2014 à la télévision dans la série
engrenage sur Canal plus avant de
retrouver la scène avec l'annonce faite
à Marie de Paul Claudel la même année un
parcours artistique pluriel qui conduit
la jeune artiste au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin
pour son récital crack in the sky j'ai
fait du piano j'ai fait 7 ans violon
mais c'est plutôt mon père qui est
violoniste donc après j'ai trouvé le
théâtre j'ai j'ai rencontré le
champ vers 17 ans vraiment même si la
musique a toujours bercé ma ma vie et
puis et j'ai toujours aimé faire des
projets qui
réunissaient le théâtre et la musique
cet ancien élève du conservatoire d'Art
Dramatique de Paris et ancienne
pensionnaire de la Comédie Française a
créé il y a 1 an un spectacle musical à
son image éclectique intense et
instinctif elle chante aussi bien en
français anglais latin araméen arabe et
espagnol elle partition rock et LAN
lyrique ou not cigan céit l'occasion de
en fait de
réunir vraiment les musiques qui me qui
font un peu des détonations chez moi
puis
donc de faire comme un tour du monde un
tour des époques un tour de vraiment
d'abollir les frontières de du genre
donc de passer ouais de l'opéra au Rock
and Roll mais comme si de trouver le
point commun quoi qui est quand même
ouais un feu
[Musique]
intérieur
ce soir mercredi 25 mai à 2h30 au
théâtre de SaintQuentin en iveline Judi
Chemla sera accompagné sur scène de
Bruno lebr à la contrebasse et bass
électrique de Gabriel Levasseur au piano
et à l'accordéon et de Thib Perriard à
la batterie it